okay we're gonna start with something uh
gut wrenching and stomach churning this
is an article written by freelance
journalists Rupa
subramanya uh which I think I got that
right on her sub stack and it's uh it's
a it's a very important article by the
way that you should go look up and and
uh and well written uh and it's quite
relevant to the topic today as it
documents the medical industry's further
plunge into moral Madness and by
extension the Wes plunge into moral
Madness so assisted suicide
is becoming increasingly popular in the
west especially in Canada
and starts in Canada and filters down
that land acknowledgment nonsense grew
uh became a prominent became popular in
Canada and is filtering down now uh in
into the United States same thing with
the expansion of assisted suicide so
popular OS especially in Canada
and in Canada the laws have been
repeatedly adjusted to make more people
eligible for this sort of
quote unquote treatment
and it's getting to getting to the point
where in some parts of Canada
assisted suicide euthanasia is one of
the leading causes of death that's how
common it is
as the author documents in this article
it's become an epidemic and now it's an
epidemic that includes very young people
even kids
so I'm going to read some of this now
on September 7th Margaret Marcilla
called Joshua Tepper the Doctor Who
planned to kill her son
Marcellus 46 she lives outside Toronto
with her husband and daughter a nursing
student
she had known that her 23 year old son
Keanu vafayan was depressed he was
diabetic and lost his vision in one eye
and he didn't have a job a girlfriend
how much of a future and Marcilla asked
her daughter to log on to keanu's
account Keanu had given his sister
access so she could help him with his
email he never shared anything with his
mother what he was thinking where he was
going and Marcilla was scared that was
what Marcilla learned that Keanu had
applied in the Late July had been
approved for medical assistance in dying
AKA made maid
AKA assisted suicide
his death was scheduled for September
22nd in a September 7th email from
Tepper the doctor to Keanu and Tecla
Hendrickson the executive director for
made house the Toronto facility where
keanu's death would take place Tepper
mapped out the schedule
here's the email
hi he emailed
I'm confirming the following time please
arrive at 8 30 a.m I will ask for the
nurse at 8 45 a.m and I will start the
procedure at around 9am procedure will
be completed a few minutes after it
starts
okay
let's pause for a second here to take
note of one of the most Insidious
aspects of assisted suicide notice the
language that's being used procedure
treatment right you're going to a
facility there's uh there's appointments
someone's emailing you to confirm the
appointment working out logistics it
sounds like a communication between uh
you know that you would have with a
dentist or something an orthodontist
and the effect is that we are sanitizing
suicide we are sanitizing death we're
making it seem like something other than
it is
and this doesn't just make suicidal
people feel better about their suicides
which would be bad enough
okay I don't see any difference between
this and you see a suicidal person who's
that who's standing at the at the at the
edge of a bridge and about to jump off
and rather than trying to convince him
to step back from the edge you just try
to make him feel better about what he's
going to do oh go ahead it'll be fine it
won't hurt that much
like if someone did that I mean if you
were to witness a scene like that
someone still suicide a person standing
at the edge of a bridge someone else
shouting to them that makes them feel
better about it it'll be painless I
promise
you would uh you would think that
person's a monster what kind of person
are you this person needs help
well they're going to throw their life
away we don't want to see that happen
and yet this is exactly what's happening
in in the case of assisted suicide and
as I'm talking about this I'm
remembering that there have been
criminal cases that I forget the girl's
name but there was a famous criminal
case
in this country a few years ago of a of
a a girl
who encouraged her boyfriend to commit
suicide
and he was depressed and she encouraged
it and she kept telling him that it'll
be fine and he was even in his car about
to commit suicide and she was coaching
him through it and saying it'll be
painless it'll be fine you know this is
how you make your problems go away
and she was charged with crime for that
and for good reason
yet this is exactly what is happening
with assisted suicide and it's happening
in a medical context and because the
person has a white coat
and can call themselves a doctor
Suddenly It's it's okay
but it's it's it's even it's even worse
than it it's not just making suicidal
people feel better about their suicide
it's also
um it's also you know making it seem
appealing
to people who otherwise wouldn't be
suicidal it encourages suicide in other
words
quite intentionally of course
the other thing to keep in mind as we go
through this and and we'll get to this
article in a moment but it's worth
emphasizing that we are way past the
point of euthanasia for elderly people
who are terminally ill and going to be
dead next week anyway and I think still
when you hear about euthanasia that's
what comes to mind but we are way past
that we're talking about putting down
like dogs
physically healthy people young people
people who should have long lives in
front of them
we are much further down the slippery
slope it is a it's a slope that some of
us warned would happen if we legalized
euthanasia at all some of this have been
warning some of us have been warning
about this for years
we said if we get if doctors get into
the business of Doling out death
as a way to to get around a problem that
you're having or to deal with a problem
they're having if it's a very serious
problem a fatal problem like a terminal
illness once doctors get into the
business of that there is no end there's
no floor there's no basement
and we warned about that and we were
ignored
but here's the thing we are always right
when we warn about the slippery slope we
are always right always always
we have never been wrong
we've been right every single time
maybe at some point people start
listening to us
you still have these morons who treat
the slippery slope oh it's a fallacy
slippery slopes of it's a fallacy it's
just it's just that we're we're right
every single time
continuing along says the procedure
entailed administering Two drugs first a
coma inducing agent then a neuromuscular
blocker that would stop keanu's
breathing he'd be dead in five to ten
minutes apparently Kano wanted to bring
a dog with him and an email to him that
same day Hendrickson said dogs are
welcome in the space as long as there's
someone there who will be responsible
for them during the time it made house
marcelo's terrified you tried to do
everything for her son but it had been
rough for him
and then it goes into what you know what
he'd gone through in his life he'd been
through a lot of very difficult things
uh he was unhappy
and that's when he decided to reach out
um about being killed
now the story doesn't really have a you
know it does there's no ending really to
the story certainly not a happy one it
goes on to say that after the mother's
efforts to fight against this the
suicide appointment was was canceled but
her son is still in despair he hates his
mom now for trying to save him
um though he he does he does he doesn't
right now have an active appointment to
kill himself so that's the positive the
negative is that you know he's far from
out of the woods and same for her the
struggle goes on
and that's how it should be right
because we fight for life we don't give
up on it and when someone's going
through
a time like it's a very very dark time
and you try to help them it's very
likely that they're going to lash out at
you they're going to start blaming you I
mean you're trying to help them and save
them and they're going to take it out on
you that's what her this guy's mom is
dealing with
but you keep fighting for it because
life is worth fighting for if it's not
then what's the point of anything
what's the point of it everyone's
worried about nuclear war we might as
well just incinerate ourselves with with
nukes on purpose and be done with it if
life is not worth fighting for and
saving
we can't get to the point where we say
well this person is depressed and uh
they'll always be like this is no point
in him living anymore let's put him down
like an old golden retriever and move on
now you keep fighting for life
uh and then the article goes on to talk
about the the numbers right now and how
in Canada especially they are rapidly
increasing you know year over year every
year more and more people uh falling
victim to euthanasia and the reason why
it's increasing is because well we live
in a culture of death that encourages
this kind of thing and encourages
Despair and also at the same time they
are relaxing and relaxing and amending
the laws to include more and more people
and now as we said they you know you
could get euthanasia even if you don't
have a terminal illness even if you're
young and now they're even talking about
amending the law again
so that children
without parental consent so that
teenagers okay minors it's it's uh what
they're called a mature minor Doctrine
under the mature minor the so-called
mature minor Doctrine
um
miners
can get euthanasia without parental
consent
so they're going to start killing
teenagers without parental consent
full-on moral collapse I mean just
complete in the West
and this is also the continued we talk
about self-immolation it's the continued
self-immolation of Medicine of the
medical profession
as it continues to
profit off of harm
many such cases
and it's really the affirm the so-called
affirmative care model brought to its
inevitable and violent uh and and quite
grotesque conclusion
we know about the affirmative care model
when it comes to gender and someone is
gender confused and in despair because
of their gender confusion uh they come
in and they have that confusion Affirmed
rather than having reality affirm they
have their confusion affirmed and then
they just fall deeper deeper into
Despair and now the same thing is
happening with depression
a depressed and suicidal person comes to
the doctor and they have their
depression and suicide confirmed and
Affirmed
rather than saying no you'll get through
this it's not going to be like this your
whole life your life is still worth
living
they're told yeah you know what if you
feel like this now you're never not
going to feel like this and so you might
as well kill yourself
so they're being told
it's just so barbaric
especially for those of us who are a
little bit older and have lived a while
and
you know we know that you can go through
times and let you can go through periods
and you can go through very dark periods
in life I mean many people have you go
through very dark periods and they they
can be so dark that you don't see an end
to it you feel lost you don't see the
light at the end of the tunnel you feel
like it's going to be like this forever
and um and then in in so many cases you
you come out of it
and maybe there'll be a time in your
life when you go back into it that
that's part of life it's life is hard
it's and there's suffering involved
but when you're in your lowest moment
and you're suffering your most it
doesn't mean it's going to be like that
forever
that should be the message that's a
message of Hope but
it's not what we're getting anymore
and that'll do it for this segment of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
friends